[موسيقى]
كانت الطائرة عبارة عن اختراع دوار جديد
تمامًا تعرفه بعد عشر سنوات فقط أو نحو ذلك
بعد أن طار الأخوان رايت لأول مرة في
البداية ، أعتقد أن جيوش أوروبا
لم تكن تعرف حقًا ما يجب فعله
بالطائرة ولكن سرعان ما اكتشفت  لقد كان
دورًا مهمًا للغاية في
تدريب الطيارين على إنتاج الطائرات والذي
ارتفع جميعًا بسرعة كبيرة جدًا ، فقد كانت طريقة جديدة تمامًا
للقتال حيث أضافت آلات الحرب
التي تعمل في الهواء
بُعدًا ثالثًا إلى ساحة المعركة
وكانوا يتعلمون فقط كيفية القيام بذلك وكذلك
الطيارين  كانوا يلقون قنابل من
قمرة القيادة وكانوا يحملون مسدسات
وبنادق في قمرة القيادة أو كان
لديهم مراقب وقمرة قيادة ثانوية
به مسدس أو بندقية
وكانوا يتداولون جولات مع طائرات أخرى
[موسيقى]
لدي الكثير  من الاحترام
للشباب الذين طاروا هذه
الطائرات البدائية حقًا إلى الوراء في اليوم في
كثير من الأحيان مع تدريب لبضعة أسابيع فقط ، لذلك
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل أن أكون طفلاً في السابعة عشر من عمره
يقفز في واحدة من  نفس الطائرات
ثم يتم إلقاؤها في القتال مقابل
أنك تعرف رجلاً آخر ربما يكون
طفلًا آخر يبلغ من العمر سبعة عشر عامًا خائفًا
من عقله أنه يحاول قتله
، أعتقد من ناحية أنهم كانوا
مرعوبين لأنهم
كانوا صغارًا عندما جاؤوا
الخطوط الأمامية مع وحدة تعرف أنها
ربما كان لديها عشرين ساعة كحد أقصى من
وقت الطيران ، لم يكونوا من
ذوي الخبرة
في مطار رينبيك القديم ، وهو الجهاز الوحيد في
الوقت الحقيقي الذي رأيته في أي
مكان في العالم تعرف أنك تخطو
عبره  الجسر المغطى هنا ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو كان في يوم من الأيام ، الآلات
التي تعرفها للناس ، الجو
مختلف تمامًا عن
الزحام والضجيج اليومي وأنت تعلم أن معظم الناس لديهم
مئات الطائرات تحلق فوق
رؤوسهم طوال اليوم ولا يبحثون
عنها أبدًا  ولكن هنا لا يسعك إلا أن تنظر إلى
كل شيء في الوقت الحاضر بشكل
إلكتروني إلى حد كبير ، فأنت مجرد
مدير أنظمة تعرفه تطير على
طيار آلي وهو أمر
حي  istory
هو تاريخ كبير جدًا لا يمكنك
الحصول عليه في أي مكان آخر
لأنه في وجهك يمكنك حرفيًا
سماعه ورؤيته وشمّه كله
مرة واحدة وهذه تجربة مختلفة تمامًا
[موسيقى]